one of our favorite Canadian simulyu
continues to impress us big time with
his hosting duties yes absolutely simu
did not disappoint during his first time
guest hosting Jimmy Kimmel Live as he
kicked off his monologue having a little
fun with celebrities like Kevin Hart and
the Kardashians
this is not unfamiliar territory for
people like me it's just another story
of an immigrant doing a job of a white
guy and getting paid 900 percent less
am I right Guillermo yeah that's
[ __ ] man
do you feel like you're paid enough for
your job grandma no they don't pay me
enough for my job
well I'm not sure if you heard Gamo but
there's actually a big Scandal that's
rocking Hollywood right now
so so here in Southern California we're
in the middle of a massive drought and
uh local officials have been sending
letters to Residents who are using too
much water
including some very notable names the
Kardashians Dwyane Wade Sylvester
Stallone and Kevin Hart among the 2 000
plus customers warned for excessive
water usage
no no before you you grab all your
pitchforks just have a little compassion
for these poor celebrities all right do
you guys even know how much water it
takes to wash a private jet
it's a lot it's a lot and by the way by
the way I get the Kardashians okay
there's a lot of them but how much water
could Kevin Hart possibly be using
Kevin Hart could take a bath in a coffee
mug
yes can we talk about the confidence
there yeah that is uh that is not an
easy job to do like I think a lot of
people think if you're an actor and
you're a good actor and he's proven he's
a very good actor he's proven his
comedic chops as well when it comes to
his acting but that is not easy what he
was doing and he just made it look so
easy something I love about every time
we see simu doing something that is not
just I don't say just but it's not like
being an actor on screen is that he goes
at it 100 every single time Charisma
with a Capital C right and just goes
yeah I belong here so I'm doing it yeah
and it just he brings everything and the
audience responds when you read the the
comments next to any of those
appearances but specifically that one
too people love it and they're like get
him his own show you know when he's done
with Marvel he could host one of these
100 I think so and and I think when you
have a personality like that and you
know how to do press he's funny in
interviews he's great on red carpets
I've interviewed him on red carpets he's
definitely a standout Kate is saying if
he's wearing this suit he can host
everything and I totally agree with you
I think it goes a long way in this
industry in Hollywood as well obviously
he's such a standout as an actor but
having that kind of personality like I
could see him becoming massive oh in
terms of his popularity like becoming
like like an A-list star yeah and I
think you know going back again to what
people say because you know we read the
comments we want to make sure how the
crowd feels how the fans feel about an
individual and like they're all on his
side oh yeah visario is saying simu is a
funny nice guy love him and that's
another thing I I swear it's the
Canadian thing we've interviewed a lot
of actors in Hollywood and you know when
you have like the Ryan Gosling and the
Ryan Reynolds and there's something
about the Canadians it's true they're
super nice